>> Harris: ALL RIGHT.
JONATHAN SERRIE, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
DR. MARTY MAKARY PROFESSOR AT
JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU BACK ON THE
PROGRAM.
LOOK, I KNOW THAT WE’RE
FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE AND THE
FACTS.
I’M CURIOUS AS TO WHY THE WHITE
HOUSE LOOKS LIKE IT IS NOT.
BECAUSE OF THE OPTICS OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> THERE IS CONTRADICTIONS.
PUBLIC PERCEIVES A LOW RISK OUT
THERE IN THE COMMUNITY AND THEY
ARE CORRECT.
I THINK WHAT YOU’LL SEE IS ONE
MORE GUIDANCE THAT’S OUT OF
STEP WITH THE REAL RISK LEVEL
OUT THERE.
ALSO PEOPLE ARE GETTING
FRUSTRATED THAT THE GOALPOSTS
ARE GETTING MOVED.
THE GOAL TO GET BACK TO A
NORMAL LIFE AND REMOVE MASK
RESTRICTIONS WAS LESS THAN 10
CASES PER 100,000.
HALF THE COUNTRY IS THERE RIGHT
NOW, HARRIS.
ABOUT A DOZEN STATES HAVE LESS
THAN 7 CASES PER 100,000.
SO WHEN PEOPLE SEE THE
GOALPOSTS MOVED AND SEE THE CDC
MOVING TWO TO THREE MONTHS LATE
CONSISTENTLY ON EVERY MAJOR
ISSUE OF THE PANDEMIC THERE
WILL BE A LOT OF FRUSTRATION
OUT THERE AND POLITICAL LEADERS
WILL NEED TO RESPOND TO THAT.
>> Harris: A "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" OP-ED ARGUES THAT
LOCKDOWNS DIDN’T STOP COVID-19
CITING A RECENT STUDY THAT
FOUND MORE VIRUS SPREAD INSIDE
HOMES THAN WORKPLACES.
SO WE’VE KNOWN THIS ALL ALONG.
BUT NOW THERE IS EVEN MORE
EVIDENCE OF IT.
THE OP-ED IS READING IN PART
THERE IS LITTLE DOUBT THAT
INFECTION WOULD SPREAD FASTER
IN CONGREGATIONS THAN SMALLER
GROUPS IF BOTH ENGAGED IN
SIMILAR PRACTICES BUT SINCE
LARGER GROUPS HAVE AN INCENTIVE
TO HAVE EXPENSIVE METHODS OF
INFECTION LARGER ORGANIZATIONS
MAY BE BETTER AT PREVENTION
THAN HOUSEHOLDS.
>> IT RAISES A GOOD POINT.
WHEN YOU TELL PEOPLE THEY NEED
TO STAY AT HOME.
THEY DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY AND
MORE LICKLY TO DO THEM IN
INDOOR GATHERINGS OR DISTANCING
OR MASK REQUIREMENTS AT THE
WORKPLACE.
THIS STUDY IS TELLING US THINGS
WE’VE ALREADY KNOWN.
RATHER THAN LOOK BACK WE NEED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE WE’VE MADE A LOT
OF MISTAKES.
WHEN WE TOLD PEOPLE TO STAY
HOME WE SHOULD HAVE TOLD THEM
TO GET OUTSIDE.
WHEN THEY TOLD PEOPLE TO WASH
THEIR HANDS WE SHOULD HAVE TOLD
THEM TO MASK UP WHEN THE
INFECTION RISK WAS HIGH.
>> Harris: MORE TEACHERS ARE
SOUNDING THE ALARM OVER THE
EFFECTS OF REMOTE SCHOOLING
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND
EDUCATORS ARE WARNING
KINDERGARTNERS MAY NEVER FULLY
RECOVER FROM THE LEARNING THAT
THEY HAVE LOST.
ONE NORTH CAROLINA SCHOOL
DISTRICT OFFICIAL WROTE THIS.
KINDERGARTEN CANNOT BE
REPLICATED EVEN BY THE VERY
BEST TEACHERS IN THE VIRTUAL
ENVIRONMENT.
LOW QUALITY KINDERGARTEN
EXPERIENCE COULD IMPACT
CHILDREN FOR A LIFETIME.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS AND HOW
THE SCIENCE REALLY PLAYS A PART
IN THIS.
HOW DO WE KNOW THIS?
>> GOSH, THIS IS REALLY
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THE RESEARCH IS FINALLY
GOING TO CATCH UP AT SOME POINT
WITH THE RESTRICTIONS THAT WERE
PUT INTO PLACE.
IT HAPPENS AFTER EVERY MAJOR
NATURAL DISASTER, ANY MAJOR
EVENT IN THE COUNTRY BE IT A
HURRICANE OR SOME MAJOR PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS.
WE FINALLY GET THE RESEARCH
THAT SHOWS THAT THE
RESTRICTIONS OR THE
IMPLICATIONS WERE FAR WORSE
THAN WE THOUGHT.
WE SAW IT AFTER HURRICANE MARIA
IN PUERTO RICO AND KATRINA IN
NEW ORLEANS.
THIS STUDY TELLS US WE MAY NEED
TO CHANGE THE CURRICULUM.
THERE IS A YEAR LOSS.
YOU DON’T JUST MAKE UP FOR THAT.
WE MAYBE NEED TO START THINGS
OFF DIFFERENTLY.
I’M CONCERNED IN AUGUST WE’LL
HAVE A MASSIVE NATIONAL DEBATE
ERUPT AROUND A PERCEPTION OF
RISK EVEN THOUGH THAT RISK IS
LOW.
AND THAT DEBATE IS NOT GOING TO
BE A HEALTHY DEBATE.
IT WILL ALLOW OUR POLITICAL
INFLUENCES TO COME IN.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW, YES, WE
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
HOW ABOUT SELLING IT WITH THE
SCIENCE AND THE FACTS?
SELL THEM.
WHY ARE WE AT A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE DON’T EVEN BELIEVE WHAT
THEY SHOULD BELIEVE BECAUSE
IT’S RIGHT THERE AND REAL?
>> I THINK TWO THINGS.
WE HAVE A COMPLETELY DISTORTED
PERCEPTION OF RISK.
TODAY WE’RE 1/10 THE LEVEL OF
THE MIDDLE OF A MILD FLU SEASON.
THE CASE FATALITY RATE IS
SIMILAR NOW THAT COVID IS IN
YOUNGER POPULATIONS.
WE’RE WELL BELOW THE LEVELS OF
A MILD FLU SEASON.
THE PERCEPTION OF RISK IS
DISPROPORTIONATE.
IF YOU DISMISS IMMUNITY AS A
WAY TO MANIPULATE PEOPLE WE
HAVE TO GET TO 85% VACCINATION
IN ORDER TO HAVE A NORMAL
EXISTENCE.
THAT IS IGNORING NATURAL
IMMUNITY.
THE REALITY IS 60% OF THE U.S.
ADULTS HAVE BEEN VACCINATED AND
HALF OF THOSE UNVACCINATED HAVE
NATURAL IMMUNITY.
IT PUTS US AROUND 80% AND THE
PUBLIC PERCEIVES A LOW RISK IN
THE COMMUNITY AND THEY’RE
CORRECT.
>> Harris: THE REASON THAT FITS
INTO THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT
CHILDREN AND SCHOOLS AND
KINDERGARTNERS IN PARTICULAR
AND HOW MUCH WORK WE NEED TO DO
IS BECAUSE WE ANTICIPATE BASED
ON WHAT IS SAID, THERE IS NO
REASON WHY WE CAN’T FLIP A
SWITCH AND RESPONSIVELY GO
FORWARD IN OUR JOURNEY AND GET
BACK TO SOME THINGS LIKE SCHOOL
FULL-TIME SO ON AND SO FORTH.
A NEW PIECE IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" SAYS THAT MANY FAMILIES
ARE HESITANT TO RETURN TO
SCHOOLS BECAUSE OF THE CHANGES
THEY’VE MADE THIS YEAR AT HOME.
QUOTE, UNQUOTE.
TEENAGERS FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES HAVE TAKEN ON HEAVY
LOADS OF PAID WORK BECAUSE SO
MANY PARENTS LOST THEIR JOB.
PARENTS MADE NEW CHILDCARE
ARRANGEMENTS TO GET THROUGH THE
LONG MONTHS OF SCHOOL CLOSURES
AND PART-TIME HOURS AND ARE NOW
LOATH TO DISRUPT ESTABLISHED
ROUTINES.
SOME FAMILIES DO NOT KNOW THAT
LOCAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE
REOPENED IN THEIR AREAS BECAUSE
OF LANGUAGE BARRIERS OR LACK OF
EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATION FROM
DISTRICTS.
YOUR LAST WORD ON THIS.
>> I THINK THERE IS AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE FROM SOME
WEALTHY WHO HAS PRIVATE TUTORS
WHO HAS A GOOD LIFESTYLE DURING
COVID.
COVID HAS BEEN GOOD TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
RENOVATING THEIR HOMES DURING
COVID.
IN INNER CITY BALTIMORE HERE IT
HAS BEEN A VERY DIFFERENT STORY.
IT IS VERY HARD TO KEEP KIDS IN
SCHOOL PRE-COVID AND COVID HAS
REALLY DISTORTED THAT ENTIRE
ABILITY TO GET KIDS IN SCHOOL
AND KEEP THEM IN SCHOOL.
>> Harris: DR. MARTY MAKARY.